well we invite you to join us you need
to remember something about this show
this show is all about common sense
something that's not real common anymore
that's why we have between 8 and 10
million listeners at any given moment
plus people that don't have common sense
like I haven't at times I've done some
pretty stupid things have you done
stupid things everybody's done stupid
things raise your hand now those of you
who didn't raise your hand you have a
problem with lying right yeah we've all
done stupid stuff we've all looked back
when we go who are you you're an idiot
oh you're me oh man we've all done that
haven't we I cannot believe I did that
you know the everybody knows they've
done stupid stuff what everybody doesn't
know is that everybody else has done
stupid stuff if you go to church you
know that at church
there's Ken and Barbie every Church has
at least one Ken and Barbie some
churches are full of them but they have
this one little couple that their kids
are perfect they're perfect their hair
is perfect they're beautiful they can
sing on key everything seems to be all
perfect you know what I'm talking about
everybody knows that you know who Ken
and Barbie are you know you can name
them right now don't lie and I'll never
forget when I first start doing
financial counseling you know the crazy
people come in and you know of course
you need financial counseling you're
freaking crazy you know that one right
and and you know Sharon and I had gone
through going broke we had lost
everything but I'll never forget the
time that finally you know I was over
the church doing a financial counseling
session one night and I look up and the
people coming in it's Ken and Barbie and
I unpack their finances oh my god they
were stupid the dumb things these people
had done were unbelievable now I got to
tell you it's not it doesn't speak well
of me and it I really I hate to admit it
but I'm gonna be truthful I was a little
bit happy I was happy that they weren't
perfect you know that's wrong I was
wrong but I came I told Sharon I said
Sharon we're not the only stupid ones
Ken and Barbie are stupid to you
believe it oh it just felt so good find
out I wasn't the only stupid one the big
myth big myth about money is is that
everybody thinks everybody else's guide
together and the truth is almost no one
does the Wall Street Journal says
seventy percent of Americans are living
paycheck to paycheck let me do that
again let's try to get the try to get a
visual for this in your mind right now
where you live on your street count out
ten houses down the street you see all
ten of them seven of them have too much
month left at the end of the money seven
of them are living like they work at
Congress they spend everything they make
and then some they buy cars they can't
afford vacations that can't afford
clothes they can't afford their kids go
to schools they can't afford and then
running up debt hand over fist they're
saving nothing in their 401ks or in
their retirement but everything looks
good on the outside in Texas they call
that big hat no cattle it's like going
to Universal Studios one time when we
were took when the kids were little we
took them there to visit and we went out
on the movie lot you know where they
shoot the streets the street scenes and
you got these little houses lined up
down the street only when you walk up to
the front door the house and you open it
there's nothing back there it's just a
facade for the lens of the camera seven
out of ten people walking around in
America that's what their lives are
they're a facade for the lens of their
friends and families camera they're
faking it they're fakes the sad thing is
that nobody that they're fooling
actually cares when you get to
retirement though you'll care because
the car you're driving if you're paying
a five hundred hour a month car payment
which is about the national average it's
going to cost you five six seven million
dollars in your retirement by the time
you get to retirement because five
hundred bucks a month invested from age
thirty to age 70
decent growth stock mutual fund and a
roth iras around five million bucks see
that's when you care because that's when
you get there and you say man I sure
hope the government which is well known
for its ability to take care of money
will take care of me I hope they've got
a plan because I didn't now I guess I'll
be one of those old people being a
greeter at Walmart guess I'll be one of
those old people working in McDonald's
now if you're an old person working at
McDonald's or Walmart I'm not mad at you
no I'm not making fun of you
but I got to tell you my goal is to not
be working at McDonald's when I'm 70
unless it's the one I own in st. Thomas
I you know really I want to do a little
better than that don't you well you're
gonna have to freaking wake up America
and quit faking it and quit lying with
your purchases because when you buy
things that you can't pay for
financially speaking that's a lie you're
living a lie and it's time to stop it's
time to get on a written gameplan be a
grown-up put on the big girl pants the
big boy pants and say I don't care from
32 it's time I grow up I don't care if
I'm 52 it's time to grow up and growing
up as adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good and we have
raised a whole culture full of grown-up
children and it's time people it's time
for a renaissance in the art of personal
finance which is about maturity it's
living like no one else so that later
you get to live and give like no one
else
you know why generosity is down because
people are freaking broke that's why you
spend everything they make and they got
nothing that's why generosity is down we
have the resources in this country to
fix most of the world's problems if we
quit being stinking consumers all the
time and faking it running ourselves so
far up in debt that we can't even
breathe it's time you guys you guys
hearing me it's time it's time to get
out your credit cards and put a piece of
scissors across them I don't care what
some idiot on some blog says cut the
stupid things up I've met with thousands
of millionaires and I've never met once
a Dave you know I mean all my money
with my Discover Points they those
airline miles that was my financial
breakthrough I'm really glad I've got
those credit cards they changed my life
that car payment changed my dadgum life
I've never met anybody that said that
that was winning with money when you're
winning with money you're doing some
things that caused that to happen it's
not an accident
you're getting out of debt so that you
have your income to invest in to give
you're doing it on a plan a written plan
you're greeing on it with your spouse
and you've learned the ancient word and
you pronounce the ancient word regularly
in your house
oh you've forgotten what the ancient
word is it's a lost word
it's a magical word it will set you free
are you ready recite the ancient word
with me America No nobody hears that
word anymore do they
that's the ancient word it's a lost word
in our vocabulary no no you can't
freaking afford it so you can't buy it
no Ramsey you're mean you're arrogant
yeah well maybe maybe I just love you
enough to tell you the truth and you're
too much of a wimp to hear it this is
the Dave Ramsey show
you